eeuu el reino unido y australia deben
jubilar cuanto antes su anticuada
mentalidad de guerra fría porque de lo
contrario sólo conseguirán dispararse en
el pie lo asegurado hoy el ministerio de
exteriores en su primera reacción la
firma del acuerdo de defensa que busca
frenar el auge de china en la región la
primera respuesta había llegado desde la
embajada china en washington y hoy la
prensa nacional ya denuncia lo que
califica como histérica política de
alianzas de eeuu alerta de que pondrá en
peligro la paz y seguridad en la región
y sostiene que el mundo debe prepararse
para una inminente fiebre por hacerse
con submarinos de propulsión nuclear
estados unidos y sus aliados sostiene el
diario 'global times' están poniendo en
peligro al mundo al ignorar los acuerdos
de no proliferación nuclear las críticas
al acuerdo también han llegado desde
australia su ex primer ministro paul
quien asegura que reducirá la soberanía
nacional y que aumentará la dependencia
de washington